la guerre du gaz a commencé après la
suspension des livraisons russes le
premier ministre bulgare s'est montré
ferme personne ne peut faire chanter la
bulgarie quel que soit le pouvoir qu'ils
pensent avoir un gisement
à seulement 10 % la proportion de gaz
est plutôt faible dans le mix
énergétique bulgare mais sofia reste
néanmoins dépendante de gazprom plus des
trois quarts de son approvisionnement
vient de la russie
une situation que certains bulgare voix
avec optimisme
pour être honnête je suis un peu content
parce que l'indépendance énergétique de
la bulgarie est plutôt bonne nous
pouvons trouver d'autres sources
un pacte énergétique ou impact politique
le pays n'a sans doute pas été choisis
au hasard par le kremlin la bulgarie est
gouvernée par une coalition
d'un côté le premier ministre or au fil
petkov qui a refusé de payer le gaz
russe en roubles comme le demandent et
poutine et qui veut fournir une aide
militaire à l'ukraine de l'autre ses
alliés socialistes russophiles qui
refusent ou menace de quitter la
coalition provoquant ainsi des
législatives anticipées dans une
position partagée par certains bulgare
attaché à l'alliance historique du pays
avec la russie
[Musique]
je pense que la réaction de la russie
est un peu extrême mais qu'elle est
largement causée par le comportement
inapproprié de notre gouvernement
d'après la presse bulgare sofia
fournirait des armes légères à kiev mais
officiellement avec la hongrie la
bulgarie est le seul pays européen à ne
pas fournir des militaires le crem